you guys have one of the most clever and
funny shows on television right now it's
just it's it's fantastic it's really
great it means a lot to me
Wow for real oh that's nice but it's it
really is it really is fantastic what I
love about it is that my wife and I
watch it with our kids who are who
exactly and they're they're 14 and 12
and we're all howling hysterically at
the show so it's nice that's rare right
very rare yeah the creators genius he's
a brilliant writer yeah that's so good
to hear thank you for saying that holy
cow you know what's cool is that you
were not too long ago I mean now you're
on this hit television show critically
acclaimed you were a nanny so pretty
recently isn't that right I was like how
how recently like very recently like the
show we're about to start our third
season right like right before the show
got picked up I was still Manning I was
dating for ten years in New York a few
years here in LA and I love nannying I
kept doing it because I loved it so much
I love babies older kids are weird
they're weird
yeah like was there a moment where you
thought like yeah this is it there are
there are so many moments but one in
particular was I was babysitting for a
weird child how old about I think he was
like six or maybe seven and I he was
kind of messy and I was picking up his
Legos and I feel I like bent over to
pick up his Legos and I feel a smack on
my bottom and I turned around like yell
at him and he looks me dead in the eye
and goes that big fat butt belongs to me
[Applause]
that kid has been born at the wrong time
he's gonna last another Mach it isn't no
changes Wow yeah exactly but I mean he
was not wrong
you